the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
to begin today I want to remind you I
need to write it down on the board at
least twice of the fundamental theorem
of calculus we called it FTC one because
it's the first version of the
fundamental theorem we'll be talking
about another version called the the
second version today and what it says is
this if F prime is equal to F then the
integral from A to B of f of X DX is
equal to F of B minus F of a that's the
fundamental theorem of calculus and the
way we used it last time was this was
used to evaluate integrals not
surprisingly that's how we used it but
today today I want to reverse that point
of view we're going to read the equation
backwards and we're going to write it
this way and we're going to use F to
understand capital F in other words the
the derivative to understand the
function so that's the
reversal of point of view that I'd like
to to make and we'll make this point in
in various ways so information about F
about F crime gives us information about
now since there were questions about the
mean value theorem I'm going to
illustrate this first by making a
comparison between the fundamental
theorem of calculus and the mean value
theorem so we're going to compare this
fundamental theorem of calculus with
what we call the mean value theorem and
in order to do that I'm going to
introduce a couple of notations all
right Delta F is f of B minus F of a and
another highly imaginative notation
Delta X is equal to B minus a so here's
the change in F there's the change in X
and then this fundamental theorem can be
written of course it's right up above
there is the formula and it's the
formula for Delta F so this is what we
call the fundamental theorem of calculus
I'm going to divide by Delta X now and
if I divide by Delta X that's the same
thing as 1 over B minus a times the
integral from A to B of f of X DX
alright so I've just rewritten the
formula here and this expression here on
the right hand side is a fairly
important one this is the average
of F that's the average value of F now
so this is going to permit me to make
the the comparison between the mean
value thing which we don't have stated
yet here and the fundamental theorem and
I'll do it in the form of inequalities
so right in the middle here I'm going to
put the fundamental theorem it says that
Delta F in this notation is equal to
well if I multiply by Delta X again I
can write it as the average of F so I'm
going to write it as the average of F
prime here times Delta X all right so we
have this factor here which is the
average of f prime or the average of
little F it's the same thing and then I
multiplied through again so I put the
thing in the in the red box right here
isn't what the average of big F so the
question is why is this the average of
little F rather than the average of big
F so the average of a function is the
typical value if for example little F
were a constant okay
little F we're a constant then this
integral would be so the question is why
is this the average and I'll take a
little second to explain that but I
think I'll explain it over here because
I'm going to erase it so the idea of an
average is the following for example
imagine that a is equal to zero and B is
equal to n let's say for example and so
we might average we might some the
function from 1 to n all right now that
would be the sum of the values from 1 to
N but the average is we divide by n here
all right so this is the average and
this is a kind of Riemann sum
representing the integral from 0 to n of
f of X DX where the increment Delta X is
1 all right so this is the notion of an
average value here but in the continuum
setting as opposed to the discrete
setting where as what's on the left hand
side is the change in F the capital F
and this is the average of the little F
ok so an average is a sum and it's like
an integral
all right so so in other words what I
have here is that the change in F is the
average of its infinitesimal change
times the amount of time elapsed if you
like so this is the the statement of the
fundamental theorem just rewritten
exactly what I wrote there but I
multiplied back by Delta X now let me
compare this with the mean value theorem
the mean value theorem also is an
equation the mean value theorem says
that this is equal to F prime of C times
Delta X now I pulled a fast one on you I
used capital F s here to make the
analogy clear but the role of the letter
is is is important to make the
transition to this comparison we're
talking about the function capital F
here and its derivative now this is true
so now I claim that this thing is fairly
specific
whereas this unfortunately is a little
bit vague and the reason why it's vague
is that C is just somewhere in the
interval so some C sorry this is some C
in between a and B so really we don't
since we don't know where this thing is
we don't know which of the values it is
we can't say what it is all we can do is
is say well for sure it's less than the
largest value say the maximum of F prime
times Delta X and the only thing we can
say for sure on the other end is that
it's less than or equal to sorry it's
greater than or equal to the minimum of
F prime times Delta X over that same
interval this is over 0 less than sorry
a less than X less than B all right so
that means that the fundamental theorem
of calculus is a much more specific
thing and indeed it gives the same
conclusion it's much stronger
and the mean value theorem it's way
better than the mean value theorem in
fact as soon as we have integrals we can
abandon the mean value theorem we don't
want it it's too simple-minded and what
we have is something much more
sophisticated which we can use which is
this so it's obvious that if this is the
average the average is less than the
maximum so it's obvious that it works
just as well to draw this conclusion and
similarly over here with the with the
minimum ok the average is always bigger
than the minimum and smaller than the
maximum all right so this is the
connection if you like and I'm going to
elaborate just one step further by
talking about the problem that you had
on the exam so there was an exam to
problem and I'll show you how it works
using the mean value theorem and how it
works using integrals but I'm going to
have to use this notation capital F so
capital F crime as opposed to little F
which was what was the notation that was
on your exam so we had this situation
here these were the Givens of the
problem and then the question was the
mean value theorem says or implies if
you like it's doesn't say it but it
implies it sorry
implies a is less than F of a capital F
of 4 is less than B for which a and B so
let's take a look at what the what it
says well the mean value theorem says
that F of 4 minus F of 0 is equal to F
prime of C times 4 minus 0 this is this
F prime times Delta X this is the change
in X
and that's the same thing as 1 over 1
plus C times 4 and so the range of
values of this number here is from 1
over 1 plus 0 times 4 that's 4 2 that's
the largest value to the smallest that
it gets which is 1 over 1 plus 4 times 4
all right that's that's the range and so
the conclusion is is that F of 4 minus F
of 0 is between well let's see it's
between 4 and 4/5 right which are those
two numbers down there and if you
remember that F of 0 is 1 this is the
same as F of 4 is between 5 and 9 fifths
all right so that's the way that you
were supposed to solve the problem on
the on the exam on the other hand let's
compare to what you would do with the
fundamental theorem of calculus with the
fundamental theorem of calculus we have
the following formula f of 4 minus f of
0 is equal to the integral from 0 to 4
of DX over 1 plus X that's what the
fundamental theorem says
and now I claim that we can get these
same types of results by a very
elementary observation it's really the
same observation that I made up here
that the average is less than or equal
to the maximum which is that the biggest
this can ever be is let's see the
biggest is is when X is zero that's one
so the biggest it ever gets is this and
that's equal to four
all right on the other hand the smallest
it ever gets to be it's equal to this
the smallest it ever gets to be is the
integral from zero to four of a fifth DX
because that's the lowest value that the
integrand takes right when X is equal to
four it's a fifth and that's equal to
4/5 okay now there's a little tiny
detail which is that really we know that
this is the area of some rectangle and
this is strictly smaller and we know
that this is these inequalities are
actually strict but that's a minor point
and certainly not one that we'll pay
close attention to but now let me let me
show you what this looks like
geometrically so geometrically we
interpret this as the area under a curve
here's the piece of the the curve of y
equals 1 over 1 plus X and it's going up
to 4 and starting at 0 here and the
first estimate that we made that is the
upper bound was by trapping this in this
in this big rectangle here
right we compared it to the constant
function which was one all the way
across this is y equals one and then we
also trapped it from underneath by the
function which was at the bottom and
this was y equals one fifth and so what
this really is is these things are the
simplest possible Riemann sums sort of a
silly Riemann sum this is a Riemann sum
with one rectangle this is the simplest
possible one and so this is a very very
crude estimated you can see it misses by
a mile the the larger and the smaller
values are off by a factor of five but
this one is called the this one is the
lower Riemann sum and that one is less
than our actual integral which is less
than the upper Riemann sum okay and you
should by now have looked at those upper
and lower sums on your homework so it's
just the rectangles underneath and the
rectangles on top all right so at this
point we can literally abandon the mean
value theorem because we have a much
better way of getting at things if we
chop things up into more rectangles
we'll get much better numerical
approximations and if we use
simple-minded expressions of with
integrals we'll be able to figure out
any bound we could get using the mean
value theorem so that's not the
relevance of the mean value theorem I'll
explain to you why we talked about it
even in a few minutes okay are there any
questions before we go on yeah I knew
that the range of C was from 0 to 4 I
should have said that right here this is
true for this theorem the mean value
theorem comes with an extra statement
which I missed which is that this is for
some C between 0 and 4 so I know the
range is between 0 and 4 the reason why
it's between 0 4 is that's part of the
mean value theorem we started at 0 we
ended at 4 so the C has to be somewhere
in between that's part of the mean value
theorem
that that's the question is do you
exclude any values that are above for
and below zero yes absolutely the point
is that in order to figure out how f
changes capital F changes between 0 & 4
you need only pay attention to the
values in between you don't have to pay
any attention to what the function is
doing below zero or above 4 there those
things are strictly irrelevant yeah
yeah I mean it's it's strictly in
between these two numbers I have to
understand what the lowest and the
highest one is that's it's approaching
that so alright okay so now the next
thing that we're going to talk about is
since I've got that one up there
that fundamental theorem of calculus one
I need to talk about version two
so here's the fundamental theorem of
calculus version two I'm going to start
out with a function little F and I'm
going to assume that it's continuous and
then I'm going to define a new function
which is defined as a definite integral
G of X is the integral from a to X of F
of T DT now I want to emphasize here
because of the first time that I'm
writing something like this that this is
a fairly complicated gadget it plays a
very basic but and very fundamental but
simple role but it nevertheless is a
little complicated what's happening here
is that the upper limit I've now called
X and the variable T is ranging between
a and X and that a and the X are fixed
when I calculate the integral and the T
is that what's called the dummy variable
it's the variable of integration you'll
see a lot of people who will mix this X
with this T and if you do that you will
get confused potentially hopelessly
confused in this class in 1802 you will
be completely lost if you do that so
don't do it don't mix these two guys up
all right it's actually done by many
people in textbooks and it's fairly
careless especially in old fashioned
textbooks but don't do it all right so
here we have this G of X now remember
this G of X really doesn't make sense if
you give me an A and you give me an X I
can figure out what this is because I
can figure out the Riemann sums of
course I need to know what the function
is - but anyway we have a numerical
procedure for figuring out what the
function G is now as is suggested by
this mysterious letter X being in the
place where it is I'm actually going to
vary X so the conclusion is that if this
is
and this is just a parenthesis it's not
part of the theorem it's just an
indication of what the notation means
then G prime equals F let me first
explain what the significance of this
theorem is from the point of view of
differential equations G of X solves the
differential equation y prime equals f
of X so y prime equals F shouldn't you
put the X in if I'd got it here with the
condition Y of a is equal to zero so it
solves this pair of conditions here the
rate of change and the initial position
is is specified here because when you
integrate from A to A you get zero
always and what this theorem says is you
can always solve that equation when we
did differential equations I said that
already I said we'll treat these as
always solved well here's the reason we
have a numerical procedure for computing
things like this we can always solve
this equation and the formula is a
fairly complicated gadget but so far
just associated with Riemann sums all
right now let's just do one example and
then we'll
let's just do one one example
unfortunately not a not a complicated
example and maybe not persuasive as to
why you would care about this just yet
but nevertheless very important because
this is the quiz question which
everybody gets wrong until they practice
it alright so the integral from say 1 to
X of DT over T squared let's try this
one here so here's an example of this
theorem I claim
now this is a question which challenges
your ability to understand what the
question means because it's got a lot of
symbols it's got the integration and
it's got the differentiation however
what it really is is an exercise in
recopying you look at it and you write
down the answer and the reason is that
by definition this function in here is a
function of the form G of X of the of
the theorem over here and by definitely
this is the G of X and by definition we
said that G prime of X is equal to f of
X well what's the f of X look inside
here it's what's called the integrand
this is the integral from 0 to X of F of
T DT right where the f of T is equal to
1 over T squared so your ability is
challenged you have to take that 1 over
T squared and you have to plug in the
letter X instead of T for it and then
write it down as I say this is an
exercise in recopying what's there
alright so this is quite easy to do
right I mean you just you just look and
you write it down but nevertheless it
looks rather it looks like a long
elaborate object here pardon me
so the question was why did I integrate
why did I not integrate ah very good
question why did I not integrate the
reason why I didn't integrate is I
didn't need to just as when you take the
antiderivative sorry the derivative is
something and taking antiderivative you
get back to the thing so in this case
we're taking the antiderivative
something that we're differentiating it
so we end back in the same place where
we started we started with f of T we're
ending with F little F all right so you
integrate and then differentiate you get
back to the same place
now the only difference between this and
the other version is in this case when
you differentiate and integrate you
could be off by a constant that's what
that shift why there are two pieces to
this one but there's never an extra
piece here there's no plus C here when
you integrate and differentiate you kill
whatever the constant is because the
derivative of a constant is zero all
right so no matter what the constant is
hiding inside of G you're getting you're
getting the same result all right so
this is this is the the basic idea now I
just want to double check it using the
fundamental theorem of calculus one here
so let's actually evaluate the integral
so now I'm going to do what you've
suggested which is I'm just going to
check whether it's true no no I am
because I'm going to just double check
that it's consistent
it certainly is is slower this way and
we're not going to want to do this all
the time but we might as well check one
so this is this is our integral and we
know how to do it no I need to do it and
this is minus T to the minus 1 evaluated
at 1 an X again there's something
subliminally here for you to think about
which is that remember it's T is ranging
between 1 and and t equals x and this is
one of the big reasons why this letter T
has to be different from X because here
it's 1 and there it's X it's not X so
you can't put an X here again this is T
equals 1 and this is T equals x over
there and now if I plug that in I get
what I get minus 1 over X and then I get
minus a minus 1 all right so this is let
me get rid of those little T's there so
this is a little easier to read
all right and so let now let's check it
it's D by DX so here's what G of X is G
of X is 1 minus 1 over X that's what G
of X is and if I differentiate that I
get plus 1 over x squared that's it you
see the constant washed away now so now
here's my job my job is to prove these
theorems I never did prove them for you
so I'm going to prove the fundamental
theorem of calculus but I'm going to do
2 first and then I'm going to do 1 and
it's just going to take me a just one
blackboard it's not that hard
the proof is by picture and using the
interpretation as area under the curve
so if here's if here's the value of a
and this is the graph of the function y
equals f of X then I want to draw three
vertical lines one of them is going to
be at X and one of them is going to be
at X plus Delta X so here I have the
interval from 0 to X and next I have the
interval from X to X of Delta X more
than that and now the pieces that I've
got are the area of this part so this
has area which has a name it's called G
of X by definition G of X which is
sitting right over here in the
fundamental theorem is the integral from
a to X of this function so it's the area
under the curve so that area is G of X
now this other chunk here
I claim that this is Delta G this is the
change in G it's the value of G of X
that is the area of the whole business
all the way up to X plus Delta X minus
the first part G of X so it's what's
left over it's the it's the incremental
amount of area there and now I just I'm
going to carry out a pretty standard
estimation here this is practically a
rectangle and it's got a base of Delta X
and so we need to figure out what its
height is this is Delta G and it's
approximately its base times its height
but what is the height well the height
is may be either this segment or this
segment or something in between but
they're all about the same so I'm just
going to put in the value at the first
point that's the left end there so
that's this height here is f of X so
this is f of X and so really I
approximated by that rectangle there and
now if I divide and take the limit as
Delta X goes to 0 of Delta G over Delta
X it's going to equal f of X and this is
where I'm using the fact that F is
continuous because I need the values
nearby to be similar to the value in the
limit
okay that's the end this is the this is
the end of the proof so I'll put a nice
little QED here alright so we've done
fundamental theorem of calculus - and
now we're ready for fundamental theorem
of calculus 1 alright so now I still
have it on the blackboard to remind you
it says that the integral of the
derivative is the function at least the
difference between the values of the
function at two places so the place
where we start is that with this with
this property that F prime is equal to F
that's the starting that's the
hypothesis now unfortunately I'm going
to have to assume something extra in
order to use the fundamental theorem of
calculus - which is I'm going to assume
that F is continuous that's not really
necessary but that's just a very minor
technical point which I'm just going to
ignore all right so we're going to start
with F prime being equal to little F and
then I'm going to go somewhere else I'm
going to define a new function G of X
which is the integral from a to X of F
of T DT now this is where we needed all
of the labor of Riemann sums because
otherwise we don't have a way of making
sense out of what this even means
all right so hiding behind this one
sentence is the fact that we actually
have a number we have a formula for such
functions so there is a function G of X
which once you've produced a little F
for me I can cook up a function capital
G for you now we're going to apply this
fundamental theorem of calculus to the
one that we've already checked so what
does it say it says that G prime is
equal to F and so now we're in the
following situation we know that F prime
of X is equal to G prime of X all right
that's that's what we've got so far and
now we have one last step to get a good
connection between F and G which is that
we can conclude that f of X is G of X
plus a constant
now this little step may seem innocuous
but I remind you that this is the spot
that requires the main value theorem so
in order not to lie to you we actually
tell you what the underpinnings of all
of calculus are and they're this the
fact if you like that if two functions
have the same derivative they differ by
a constant or that if a function has
derivatives zero it's a constant itself
now that's that is the the fundamental
step that's needed the underlying step
that's needed and unfortunately there
aren't any proofs of it that are less
complicated than using the mean value
theorem and so that's why we talked a
little bit about the mean value theorem
because we don't want to lie to you
about what's really going on yes
the question is how did I get from here
to here and the answer is that if G
prime is a little F and we also know
that F prime is little F then F prime is
G prime okay other questions
all right so we're almost done I just
have to work out the arithmetic here so
I start with F of B minus F of a and
that's equal to G of B plus C minus G of
a plus C and then I canceled the C's so
I have here G of B minus G of a and now
I just have to check what each of these
is so remember the definition of G here
G of B is just what we want the integral
from A to B of f of X DX well I call it
F of TDT that's the same as f of X DX
now because I have the limit being B and
I'm allowed to use X as the dummy
variable okay
now the other one I claim is zero
because it's the integral from a to a
alright this one is the integral from A
to A which gives us zero so this is just
this minus zero and that's the end
that's it this is I started with F of B
minus F of a I got to the integral
question
how do I get from F of B minus F of a is
G of B plus C minus G of a plus C that's
the question there though sorry this is
an equal sign sorry the second line
didn't draw okay
equals because we're plugging in for f
of X the formula for yes this this step
here or this one the right so that was a
that was a good question
but the answer is that that's the
statement that we're aiming for that's
the fundamental theorem of calculus one
which we don't know yet so we're trying
to prove it and that's why we haven't we
can't assume it yeah okay so so let me
just notice that in the example that we
had before we go on to something else
here in the example above what we had
was was the following thing we had uh we
had say f of X is equal to minus 1 over
X so f prime of X is 1 over x squared
and say G of X is equal to 1 minus 1
over X and you can see that either way
you do that if you've integrate from 1
to 2 let's say which is what we had over
there DT over T squared you're going to
get either minus 1 over T 1 to 2 or if
you like 1 minus 1 over T 1 to 2 so this
is the F version this is the G version
and that's what plays itself out here in
this
in this general proof all right so now I
want to go back to the theme for today
which is using little F little F to
understand a capital F in other words
using F the derivative of F to
understand capital F and I want to
illustrate it by some more complicated
examples so I guess I just erased it but
we just took the antiderivative of 1
over T squared and there's all of the
powers work easily but a 1 and the
tricky one is the power 1 over X so
let's consider the differential equation
L prime of X is equal to 1 over X and
say with the initial value L of 1 is
equal to 0 this the solution so the
fundamental theorem of calculus 2 tells
us the solution is this function here L
of x equals the integral from 1 to X DT
over T that's how we solve all such
equations we just integrate take the
definite integral and I'm starting at 1
because I insisted that L of 1 be 0 so
that's the solution to the problem and
now the thing that's interesting here is
that we started from a polynomial we
started from a rational ratio of
polynomials that is 1 over T or 1 over X
and we get to a function which is
actually what's known as a
transcendental function it's not an
algebraic function yeah question
the question is why is this equal to
that right and the answer is it's for
the same reason that this is equal to
that it's the same reason as this it's
that the ones cancel we've taken the
value of something at two minus the
value at one the value at two minus the
value at one and you'll get a one in the
in the one case and you'll get a one in
the other case in it you subtract them
and they will cancel they'll give you
zero these two things really are equal
this is not a function evaluated at one
place it's the difference between the
function evaluated two and the value at
one and whenever you subtract two things
like that constants drop out that's
right if I put two here if I put C here
it would have been the same it would
just have dropped out it's not it's not
there and that's exactly this arithmetic
right here it doesn't matter which
antiderivative you take when you take
the differences the C's will cancel
you'll always get the same answer in the
end that's exactly why I wrote this down
so that you would see that it doesn't
matter which one you do all right so we
still have a couple of minutes left here
this is actually so let me go back so
here's the antiderivative of 1 over x
with value 1 at 0 now in disguise we
know what this function is we know this
function is the logarithm function but
this is actually a better way of
deriving all of the formulas for the
logarithm this is it much quicker and
more efficient way of doing it we had to
do it by very laborious processes this
will allow us to do it very easily and
so I'm going to do that next time
but rather than do that now I'm going to
point out to you that we can also get
truly new functions
okay so there are all kinds of new
functions so the first example this time
kind would be for example to solve the
equation y prime is equal to e to the
minus x squared with y of zero is equal
to zero let's say now the solution to
that is a function which again I can
write down by the fundamental theorem
it's the integral from 0 to X of e to
the minus T squared DT this is a very
famous function this shape here is known
as the bell curve and it's the thing
that comes up in probability all the
time
this shape e to the minus x squared and
our function is geometrically just the
area under the curve here this is f of X
if this place is X so I have a geometric
definition I have a way of constructing
what it is by Riemann sums and I have a
function here but the curious thing
about f of X is that f of X cannot be
expressed in terms of any function
you've seen previously
so logs Exponential's trig functions
cannot be it's a totally new function
nevertheless we'll be able to get any
possible piece of information we would
want to out of this function it's
perfectly acceptable function it will
work just great for us just like any
other function just like the log and
what this is analogous to is the
following kind of thing if you take the
circle the ancient Greeks if you like
already understood that if you have a
circle of radius one then its area is
pot so that's a geometric construction
of what you could call a new number
which is outside of the realm of what
you might expect and the weird thing
about this number pie is that it is not
the root of an algebraic equation with
rational coefficients it's what's called
transcendental meaning it's just
completely outside of the realm of
algebra and indeed the logarithm
function is called a transcendental
function because it's completely out of
the realm of algebra it's only in
calculus that you come up with with this
kind of thing so so these kinds of
functions will have access to a huge
class of new functions here all of which
are important tools in science and
engineering so see you next time